la séance est
reprise l'ordre du jour appelle une
déclaration du gouvernement suivie d'un
débat en application de l'article 50-1
de la
Constitution relative à la situation au
Proche
Orient euh la parole est pour un rappel
au règlement je crois au président Hervé
Marseille
oui monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres madame la Première ministre
pardon je voudrais faire un rappel au
règlement en me fondant sur l'article 29
bis du du règlement
concernant une résolution que nous
avions déposé avec signé par plusieurs
présidents de groupe de cette assemblée
qure président taot le président maluré
et le président patria je voulais vous
dire que nous avons été étonnés de
d'observer que cette résolution n'avait
pas été inscrite à l'ordre du jour par
le gouvernement que nous n'avions pas
été prévenu en tous les cas moi j'ai pas
été prévenu en tant que signataire ce
que j'aurais aimé être et ce qui marque
quand même une certaine réserve
vis-à-vis du du Parlement j'ajoute que
cette résolution elle disait des choses
simples elle qualifiait les faits de ce
qui ve arriver en disant que le Hamas
éit un mouvement terroriste qui s'était
comporté de façon ignoble et que nous
demandions que ce qui pouvait être
qualifié de crime contre
l'humanité puisse faire l'objet d'une
instruction de la part de la France
devant la Cour de justice internationale
je pense que ce qu'on a fait pour les
Bouddhas de Bamian en Afghanistan peut
être fait pour les populations
massacrées en Israël et
donc nous aurions en plus si je puis
dire à à la faveur de cette résolution
avoir un débat bien sûr mais aussi voter
ce qui ne sera pas le cas maintenant
puisque ce qui nous est proposé c'est un
débat au titre de l'article 50-1
c'est-à-dire que il va y avoir une
succession de de discours mais il n'y
aura pas de vote à la sortie donc on ne
sait pas ce que pensent les uns et les
autres donc voilà monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre messieurs
les ministres que je voulais dire ant
que nous n'ons pas pu discuter de de
cette résolution il y a maintenant un
débat au titre de l'article 50-1 bien
nous allons débattre c'est mieux que
rien mais je regrette vraiment que nous
nai pas nous n'ayons pas pu avoir cette
discussion dans le cadre de la
résolution et que nous n ayons pas pu
voter c'est là le principal objet de mon
intervention monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
président acte et donné de votre rappel
au
règlement je vais maintenant donner la
parole à madame la Première ministre
Madame Élisabeth B madame la Première
ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
ces dernières semaines ont été marquées
par un retour brutal et tragique de la
violence au proche-
Orient un retour aux conséquences
lourdes qui inquiète beaucoup de nos
concitoyens dans ce contexte vos
interrogations sont légitimes et
débattre de la situation était un
impératif démocratique je voudrais
peut-être insister sur le caractère
extrêmement évolutif de la situation et
c'est évidemment le cas avec le
déplacement en ce moment même du
président de la
République comme je l'ai fait hier à
l'Assemblée nationale je ne peux pas
m'exprimer devant vous sans commencer
par revenir sur les faits le 7 octobre
dernier une attaque terroriste barbare a
été menée par le Hamas et le Djihad
islamique contre l'État
d'Israël des crimes odieux ont été
commis des centaines de civils ont été
massacrés
des jeunes ont été sauvagement
assassinés lors d'une fête des actes
monstrueux ont été perpétrés dans des
kibuts comme à Berry faraza ou
REIM avec une brutalité sauvage des
femmes des hommes des personnes âgées
des enfants ont été enlevés ou
assassinés au total près de 1400
personnes ont été tuées dans les
attaques terroristes de ce mois
d'octobre et si 4 ages ont été libérés
plus de 200 personnes sont encore
retenues parmi les victimes 30 de nos
compatriotes ont été tués et neuf sont
encore retenus en otage ou porté
disparu cette attaque n'était en rien
comparable aux épisodes de violence
comme comme il y en a malheureusement eu
d'autres dans l'histoire de cette région
ce déchaînement de barbarie commandité
et mis en œuvre par le Hamas montre un
changement de nature et
d'échelle il s'agissait d'une action
complexe et préméditée qui visait à
atteindre Israël et sa population en son
cœur avant de poursuivre mon propos je
tenais à rappeler ce
bilan tout comme le président de la
République a eu l'occasion de le faire
encore ce matin et comme je l'ai déjà
fait devant vous je veux dire une
nouvelle fois ma solidarité envers le
peuple israélien dans cette
épreuve je veux avoir une pensée
particulière pour nos ressortissants
notamment pour les victimes françaises
et les disparus pour leurs proches leurs
familles dès son arrivée en Israël ce
matin le président de la République a
rencontré individuellement les familles
des victimes et des disparus pour les
assurer de notre plein soutien et de
notre accompagnement dans le deuil et
l'inquiétude nous sommes à leur côté
nous partageons leur
peine mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
minimiser justifier voir absoudre le
terrorisme c'est acceptter qu'il frappe
à nouveau demain en Israël en France ou
partout
ailleurs nous ne devons faire preuve
d'aucune ambiguité face à de tels
crimes le président de la République l'a
encore affirmé avec force tout à l'heure
au côté du Premier ministre Israël
Israël a droit à la sécurité Israël a le
droit de se défendre dans le respect du
droit
international et ceux qui confondent le
droit du peuple palestinien à disposer
d'un état et la justification du
terrorisme commettent une faute morale
politique et
stratégique soyons très clair le Hamas
ne porte pas la cause
palestinienne l'autorité palestinienne
et notre interlocuteur légitime qui se
bat depuis des années pour la paix et a
besoin de notre
soutien le président de la République
s'entretient d'ailleurs en ce moment
même avec le président mmoud Abbas
aramala en agissant comme il l'a fait le
Hamas a exposé délibérément de manière
criminelle et cynique toute la
population de Gaza il utilise les
populations civiles comme boucliers
humain il met en péril les espoirs de
paix dont le peuple palestinien a tant
besoin si je souhaitais commencer par
rappeler le bilan tragique des attaques
terroristes de ce mois
d'octobre si je m'apprête à évoquer les
milliers de victimes civil de Gaza et la
situation humanitaire épouvantable dans
la zone c'est parce que nous ne devons
pas perdre de vue l'ampleur et la
gravité de la crise qui se joue il y a
des morts il y a des familles brisées
c'est une
tragédie je l'ai dit clairement hier il
n'y a pas de victime qu'il conviendrait
de pleurer moins que d'autres il n'y a
pas de vie qui Val moins que d'autres
nous sommes aussi au côté des familles
palestiniennes
endeuillé dans chacune de nos
interventions nous aurons l'occasion de
faire entendre nos sensibilités
politiques et nos différences mais face
à la gravité de la situation j'ai
confiance dans le Sénat pour débattre en
responsabilité
avec la mesure et la hauteur de vue qui
caractérise cette assemblée et que la
situation
exige mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs depuis le 7 octobre le
président de la République a été en
contact très étroit avec les autorités
israéliennes il a porté un message clair
qu'il a encore répété tout à
l'heure Israël a évidemment le droit de
se défendre face au terrorisme les
civils doivent être épargnés
la réponse militaire doit se faire dans
le respect du droit international
notamment du droit international
humanitaire les populations ne doivent
pas payer pour les crimes des
terroristes notre pays ne connaît que
trop bien le lourd tribut des attentats
et nous devons l'affirmer avec force
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme il ne
s'agit jamais de se
renier si le terrorisme doit être
combattu la réponse des démocraties doit
être juste même dans les combats les
plus dures les plus âpres nous ne devons
jamais perdre de vue ce qui fait de nous
des
démocraties notre amitié et notre
solidarité avec le peuple israélien nous
nous oblige à formuler cet appel Israël
ne doit pas tomber dans le piège du
Hamas plusieurs milliers de Palestiniens
sont morts à Gaza dont plus de 2000
enfants des journalistes et plusieurs
dizaines d'employés des Nations Unies
ont été tués les 2 millions d'habitants
de Gaza sont dans une situation d'une
extrême gravité ces milliers de vies
fauchées nous touchent au
cœur mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
dans ce contexte le gouvernement est
mobilisé sur plusieurs fronts et nous
avons pris ces derniers jours les
mesures urgentes et immédiates qui
s'imposaient tout d'abord nous agissons
depuis la première heure pour la
sécurité de nos
ressortissants une cellule a
immédiatement été activé au Centre de
Crise du ministère des Affaires
étrangères les services du quai d'orsé
notamment notre ambassade et notre
consulat général à TelAviv notre
consulat général à Jérusalem travaille
jour et nuit pour assurer un soutien aux
familles de nos compatriotes porté
disparu ou tué dans les
attaques bien sûr nous accordons une
attention particulière aux familles des
disparus je l'ai dit le président de la
République s'est entretenu avec elle ce
matin dès son arrivée en Israël
nous sommes en lien permanent avec ces
familles pour répondre à leurs
inquiétudes s'agissant des otages le
président de la République a rappelé
aujourd'hui que notre première priorité
était leur libération nous mettons tout
en œuvre pour l'obtenir au plus vite et
sans
conditions nous sommes par ailleurs en
lien avec la Communauté française sur
place pour lui apporter le soutien
nécessaire en 2 semaines la France a
permis à 3 de nos compatriotes de
rejoindre le territoire national depuis
Israël avec l'affrêement de moyens
civils et le soutien de nos armée je
n'oublie pas les dizaines de Français
bloqués à Gaza dans des conditions
extrêmement précaires nous gardons un
contact très régulier avec eux nous
poursuivons nos efforts pour qu'ils
puissent quitter la
zone permettez-moi de rendre une
nouvelle fois hommage aux diplomates aux
militaires aux fonctionnaires français
engagés sans compter dans cette
situation très éprouvante
ensuite la France est mobilisée pour
venir en aide aux populations de
Gaza à Gaza nous devons regarder en face
l'ampleur de la catastrophe humanitaire
en cours plus d'un million de personnes
ont été déplacées l'accès au services
essentiel est quasiment interrompu la
nourriture et le fuel manque les civils
n'ont plus d'eau les hôpitaux sont
saturés personne ne peut rester
insensible face à ce drame
humanitaire derrière l'ampleur des
bilans macabres il y a des femmes et des
hommes il y a des familles il n'y a pas
de nationalité d'origine ou de religion
qui vaille pour mesurer la gravité des
événements quand des civil Meur chaque
vie civile perdue est un échec pour la
communauté
internationale les populations
palestiniennes ne peuvent être abandonné
à leur propre sort notre solidarité avec
elle ne saurait être mise en cause
c'est pourquoi nous demandons une trêve
humanitaire qui permette un accès sûr et
immédiat pour l'acheminement d'eau de
nourriture de foule et d'aide
humanitaire et médicale à Gaza cet accès
doit se faire sous lesgit des Nations
Unies et la sécurité des personnels
humanitaires être
garantie même si plusieurs convois ont
désormais pu franchir la porte de Rafa
entre l'Égypte et la bande de Gaza c'est
encore insuffisant nous appelons à ce
que que la porte de Rafa reste ouverte
pour qu'une aide à la hauteur de la
situation puisse être fournie aux
populations
civiles comme l'a souligné la ministre
Catherine Colona au Ker ce weekend la
distribution d'aide exige une trêve
humanitaire qui pourra mener à un cesser
le feu nous demandons cette trêve au
plus vite c'est un point important et je
le répète face au contre contrevérité
diffusé notamment par la propagande
russe au Conseil de sécurité la France a
soutenu le projet de résolution présenté
par le Brésil dans cet objectif la
ministre des Affaires étrangères est
aujourd'hui à New York précisément pour
faire avancer les négociations au
Conseil de sécurité nous appelons à
mettre fin le plus vite possible à cette
période de
violence de plus comme le président de
la République l'a affirmé tout à l'heure
l'urgence est à rétablir l'électricité
dans les
hôpitaux la France a toujours soutenu
les populations civiles palestiniennes
elle a ainsi fourni près de 100 millions
d'euros d'aide pour les Palestiniens en
2022 cette aide est concentrée dans les
secteurs vitaux l'eau la santé
l'éducation
l'agriculture face à la situation
actuelle comme l'a annoncé le président
de la République nous avons décidé d'une
aide supplémentaire de 10 million
d'euros et nous enverrons prochainement
un avion de fret humanitaire pour
soutenir la population de Gaza en outre
face à l'urgence l'Union européenne a
répondu présent
le montant de son aide humanitaire à
Gaza a été triplé et deux vols ont
permis d'acheminer plus de 50 50 tonnes
d'aide à la
frontière le Conseil européen de cette
fin de semaine sera l'occasion de
revenir sur le sujet et de faire un
point sur le soutien que l'Europe peut
apporter puisque j'évoque l'aide que
nous apportons à la population
palestinienne de Gaza je voulais en
profiter pour revenir sur certaines
questions soulevées ces derniers jours
il est légitime de s'interroger et de
veiller à ce que notre aide humanitaire
ne puisse pas tomber entre de mauvaises
mains pour autant gardons-nous de
jugements attif et définitif qui ne se
fonde que sur une vision biaisée des
faits comme je l'ai dit hier les
procédures mises en place pour éviter
tout détournement de notre aide par le
Hamas ou le Djihad islamique sont
stricts et scrupuleusement
respecté d'abord notre aide bilatérale
comme pour tous nos partenaires est
fourni avec la accord de la communauté
internationale dont Israël selon des
procédures agréées
ensuite notre aide est mise en œuvre par
des agences de l'ONU et porte sur des
projets concrets comme je l'ai évoqué
enfin les aides sont contrôlé par
l'administration israélienne elle-même
c'est le cas pour nous comme pour nos
partenaires mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le troisième pilier de
l'action de la France c'est la
mobilisation pour pour éviter un
embrasement
régional depuis la première heure le
président de la République la ministre
des Affaires étrangères et le ministres
des armées ont multiplié les échanges
avec leurs homologues de la région le
président de la République est
aujourd'hui en Israël où il a pu marquer
notre solidarité envers les familles et
faire entendre la voix singulière de la
France en faveur d'un processus
politique permettant d'éviter
l'escalade le président de la République
a été clair sur la responsabilité
attendue de certains acteurs de la
région afin d'éviter un embrasement
régional il a également proposer de
bâtir une coalition régionale et
internationale pour lutter contre les
groupes terroristes qui nous menacent
tous nous y travaillerons activement
avec nos partenaires
internationaux mais nous le savons la
lutte implacable contre le terrorisme ne
peut remplacer la recherche de la paix
la France plaide et plaidera pour un
règle rglement durable du conflit autour
d'une solution à deux états les
conditions sont claires des garanties
indispensable pour la sécurité d'Israël
et un état pour les
Palestiniens c'est la ligne que la
France défend avec constance et qu'elle
continuera à porter la sécurité durable
d'Israël la lutte résolue pour
l'éradication du terrorisme dans la
région et le respect des aspirations
légitimes de chacun forme un ensemble
indissociable les États de la région ont
à ce titre une responsabilité
particulière la dynamique de
normalisation des relations entre Israël
et plusieurs des États de la région est
souhaitable elle doit s'accompagner
d'une d'une relance décisive du
processus politique pour répondre aux
aspirations légitimes des Palestiniens
et des
Israéliens notre responsabilité est
grande et nous l'assumons la France est
capable de parler à tout le monde le
président de la République sera
d'ailleurs ce soir à
Haman cette position indépendante nous
l'avons toujours assumé une position qui
nous donne un rôle pivot pour aider à
tracer le chemin de la paix Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénateur la situation au
Proche Orient est complexe elle est
difficile elle conduit à des drames
épouvantables comme nous avons encore pu
le mesurer ces derniers jours
elle a des conséquences lourdes sur la
sécurité internationale
elle trouve un écho particulier dans
chaque pays dans ce contexte la France a
une voix
singulière une voix issue d'une longue
histoire qui nous confère une
responsabilité une voix qui ne méconnaît
aucune des souffrances et défend
toujours l'exigence de justice et le
respect du droit humanitaire cette voix
la France continuera inlassablement à la
porter nous n'avons pas le droit de
renoncer la seule solution c'est la paix
je vous remercie
merci madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre dans la suite de notre débat la
parole est maintenant aux orateurs des
groupes monsieur le président Bruno
rotillot pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicainsur
président ministre messieurs les
ministres finalement c'est un débat ça
n'est pas une résolution c'est un débat
c'est un débat sans vote et je m'associe
au rappel au règlement que vient de
faire à l'entrée de la
séance mon collègue HERV Marseille la
différence entre une résolution et un
débat c'est le vote et cette résolution
est importante parce que le vote permet
à
chacun de s'engager et surtout la raison
d'être d'une assemblée du Parlement
c'est la
délibération nous allons donc débattre
entre-temps un professeur de français
est mort il était frappé par la bêti
monde islamiste sur le sol de
France sur le sol sacré de l'école
républicaine et finalement cet événement
monstrueux parce que c'est un événement
monstrueux renforce encore plus cette
nécessité de voir notre assemblée
débattre et surtout s'exprimer sur ces
événements qui sont liés pourquoi parce
que d'une part je le disais tout est lié
et ce qui se passe là-bas nous concerne
ici en même temps et parce que notre
réponse ne peut pas souffrir ne peut pas
supporter la moindre ambiguité la
moindre
hésitation pourquoi est-ce que ce qui se
passe là-bas nous concerne pourquoi
est-ce que nous sommes directement
concernés nous sommes triplement je
crois nous le sommes d'abord parce que
nous partageons avec le peuple juif juif
mais comme avec tous les peuples du
monde la même condition humaine
et ce qui est inhumain ne doit pas nous
être étranger comment ne pas être
horrifié par les images qui nous sont
arrivés comment ne pas être horrifié par
ces familles brûlé et vives par ces
femmes enceintes et ventré par ses
enfants nouveau né décapités
décapités symbole de l'innocence les
enfants parce que
juif comment ne pas être horrifié par
ces exactions qui constituent un crime
contre l'humanité oui her Marseille un
crime contre l'humanité et que comment
ne pas y voir dans cette violence
paroxistique comment ne pas y voir la
poursuite de l'entreprise génocidaire
par d'autres moyens rappelez-vous les
toutsis ont été massacrés à l'arme
blanche c'était à la machette donc nous
sommes concernés d'abord ce lien il est
là dans notre humanité
commune ce lien il est
aussi par cette
alliance par cette amitié par tous ces
liens qui sont irrévocables avec Israël
lien
historique forgé dans le
creuser de nos racines
judéo-chrétiennes des liens culturels
des liens civiques parce que nous
partageons avec Israël les valeurs
communes de la démocratie si rare au
Proche Orient
et je voudrais simplement dire que c'est
au nom de cette amitié à la fois
spirituelle et et civique que les
terroristes nous visent veulent nous
détruire comme ils veulent détruire
Israël tout simplement parce que sur
l'échelle de la mécréance
nous sommes si j'ose dire au sommet nous
en raison de notre laicité et Israël
parce que c'est le peuple
juif et enfin nous sommes
liés nous sommes liés par le sang versé
par le sang français
verset au moment je vous parle madame la
Première ministre 30 de nos compatriotes
sont morts 30 de nos compatriotes sont
morts et Dominique Bernard a été
lâchement assassiné le S franç TR
verersé et les images insoutenables
qu'on a pu découvrir nous rappellent
d'autres images qui nous hent encore
celle des images des attentats et plus
qu'aucun autre peuple sur la planète je
pense que le peuple français se doit de
se tenir au côté du peuple juif parce
que nous avons connu la même morsure la
même morsure sanglante du
terrorisme du totalitarisme islamiste
alors que faire désormais que faire
d'abord bien sûr nous tenir au côté
d'Israël je voudrais simplement rappeler
un point qui me paraît fondamental et
vous l'avez abordé madame la Première
ministre dans votre
intervention ce qui s'est passé cette
violence inouie ça n'est pas
l'expression désespérée d'une cause de
la cause palestinienne c'est la
résurgence du totalitarisme islamiste
que ce soit bien clair le Hamas bien sûr
ne porte pas la cause palestinienne
ilinr
il instrumentalise il la défigure il la
défigure en l'islamisant en la
talibanisant en la
déshumanisant et je voudrais simplement
rappeler à tous les Islam gauchiste qui
se déshonore en refusant de qualifier en
refusant de qualifier de
terroriste les crimes qui ont été commis
je voudrais simplement faire quelques
rappels le Hamas c'est pas un mouvement
de libération c'est un acronyme qui
signifie d'ailleurs mouvement de
résistance islamique l'inspirateur qui
n'est plus leassine son crédau ça n'est
pas de libérer la Palestine son crédau
c'était de soumettre la Palestine à la
charia à la loi islamiste il y a des
écrits il y a des dir les choses doivent
être
claires et tous les efforts du Hamas
depuis des années consistait très
clairement à saboter tous les efforts de
paix y compris les accords d'Oslo et
aujourd'hui ce qu'il s'agit de faire à
travers ce crime contre l'humanité c'est
évidemment empêcher toute réconciliation
et notamment entre Riyad Etta la vive
sans doute au bénéfice de l'Iran et
l'Iran vraisemblablement personne ne le
dit je le dis et vraisemblablement
derrière cette opération par différents
moyens les choses de ce point de vuelà
doivent être très très clair mais nous
devons pour ce qui nous concerne être
très ferme très ferme pour dire que il
faut tirer tous les enseignements un en
matière d'antisémitisme la tolérance et
la tolérance zéro même quand
l'antisémitisme avance masqué derrière
l'antisionisme je voudrais simplement
rappeler une formule oubliée de Jean
kellevic grand philosophe Jean kelevic
qui disait que l'antisionisme en réalité
c'estit bien pratique parce que il
permettait
l'antisémitisme sans le racisme c'est
exactement cela ce que je vous demande
madame la Première ministre c'est une
tolérance zéro vis-à-vis de ces
nouvelles formes d'antisémitisme parce
que l'antisémitisme en France a
muté dans ses ressorts aussi bien
politiques y compris dans ses ressorts
religieux il faut absolument en en tenir
compte deuxème élément là encore vous
l'avez indiqué
pas un€ ne doit aller à une organisation
de type terroriste comme le Anas pas 1 €
bien sûr que on peut pas retenir les
fonds humanitaires mais on doit par un
travail de contrôle extrêmement
rigoureux tout vérifier chez nous nos
aides mais aussi les aides européennes
qui constituent un paquet important
c'est absolument fondamental et je
voudrais simplement aussi pour terminer
dire que on peut parfaitement être au
côté
d'Israël reconnaître à Israël le droit
de se défendre en rappelant
évidemment que toute victime civile est
toujours un drame bien sûr que la prix
la vie des uns vaut la vie des
autres riposter éradiquer deamass dans
le cadre du droit international parce
que l'honneur des démocraties ça n'est
jamais de de s'abaisser aux valeurs de
ceux qui justement voudrai nous tirer
vers le bas bien sûr donc se tenir au
côté d'Israël fermement de façon
déterminé j'ai écouté moi aussi les
propos du président de la République à
quelques heures ça signifie évidemment
le reconnaître le droit de se défendre
d'éradiquer le Hamas d'éradiquer le
Hamas mais c'est aussi Leuret tenir un
langage de vérité ce langage de vérité
c'est de dire que depuis 30 ans depuis
an aucune guerre n'a été gagnée sans
solution
politique les Américains l'ont l'ont
appris en
Afghanistan en Irak nous l'avons appris
nous les français en Afrique au
Sahel il faut le redire bien sûr qu'il
faut éradiquer le Hamas mais une
solution politique devra être trouver
une espérance vis-à-vis aussi du peuple
palestinien devra se lever cette
espérance nous l'avons toujours proclamé
c'est la ligne française de la
diplomatie française c'est aussi la
ligne du Sénat ça a toujours été la
solution à deux états alors évidemment
prononcer aujourd'hui à cette tribune
cette perspective qui nous paraît
terriblement éloigné paraît totalement
illusoire utopique mais il faut le
rappeler on le voit bien que après
toutes ces années d'un conflit qui était
en quelque sorte gelé que aujourd'hui la
violence est
revenue mais encore une fois
Israël a le droit de se défendre et il
faut minimiser bien sûr au maximum les
victimes civiles mais c'est le Hamas qui
a déclenché les hostilités et c'est le
Hamas qui abolit toute distinction entre
les civils et les militaires en prenant
les civils comme des boucliers il faut
rappeler cette évidence et en même temps
déployer tous nos efforts diplomatiques
à l'avenir dans les mois prochains pour
que la France puisse promouvoir et nous
avons un rôle une responsabilité par
vous azpp madame la Première ministre
cette solution à de étap pour conclure
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que ce
combat c'est à nouveau le combat sans
cesse
recommencé contre le terrorisme
islamiste bien sûr au moment je vous
parle le totalitarisme islamiste ne
s'est jamais aussi bien porté dans le
monde
jamais malgré les interventions
occidentales il règne à Kabou il revient
en Irak il s'étend il se répend en
Afrique au Sahel et il frappe en France
bien sûr qu'il faut être intraitable et
la réponse et notre réponse aussi au
terrorisme doit être une réponse
judiciaire
policière législative
peut-être mais ça doit être une réponse
totale une réponse globale ce que je
veux dire c'est que et ça peut paraître
très paradoxal
mais en nous désignant comme leurs
ennemis les terroristes islamistes en
nous
désignant en ciblant l'école la
laïcité il nous montre un chemin de
résistance il nous montre la voix par
laquelle on peut répondre cette réponse
on le voit bien c'est l'idéal
républicain par exemple de la lacité
c'est cette école qui le creusait par
laquelle on transmet pas seulement des
connaissances des compétences
individuelles mais on transmet une
grandmère collective qui permettra de
main des citoyens d'intégrer pleinement
le destin national l'école c'est ce
creuser d'un idéal français avec l'idéal
républicain mais pour l'URE madame la
Première ministre messsieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues pour leur
réaffirmant
solennellement solennellement n'oublions
pas les victimes je trouve qu'on passe
trop vite par perte et profilé victime
en Israël n'oublions pas et réaffirmons
solennellement ici au Sénat dans notre
haute assemblée le soutien indéfectible
notre solidarité solidarité française à
la nation israélienne au peuple juif
parce que aujourd'hui il porte le
flambeau de la démocratie au prix du
sang dans cette région du Proche Orient
merci de votre attention
merci merci monsieur le
président
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant au président
canner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain parole monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la premierre ministre messieurs les
ministres permettez-moi de commencer C
propos par une
citation la violence il faut la dénoncer
il faut la vomir il faut l'isoler ce
n'est pas la voix des
démocraties ces mots sont ceux prononcés
par le Premier ministre yitrak Rabin le
4 novembre
1995 lors du grand meeting pour la paix
place des rois d'Israël à telavive ces
mots raisonnent en nous dans cette
terrible actualité
quelques minutes plus
tardraabin était
assassiné les heures sombres de
l'obscurantisme sont de retour les actes
terroristes qui ont été perpétrés le 7
octobre dernier doivent nous révolter et
je vous invite à écouter les mots du
colonel Weissberg en charge de
l'opération d'identification des
victimes je m'excuse tout de suite pour
la dureté de la description que je vais
vous faire je
cite que dire lorsque vous découvrez le
corps d'une femme enceinte tuée par un
terroriste qui lui a ouvert le ventre
puis on a extrait le fétus avant de leur
couper la tête à tous les deux et que
dire encore face au corps des mères ou
de grand-mères qui ont été violé
sauvagement mes chers collègues le
massacre de femmes d'hommes et d'enfants
dans les kibutsim du Sud d'Israël doit
nous révolter de la même manière des
enfants qui meurent sous les
bombardements des civils privés d'eau
d'électricité de nourriture toute une
population prise en en étau doit nous
révolter de telles atrocités doivent
être nommé dénoncé ne pas le faire
serait insupportable et inexcusable même
même si nous avons identifier le fait
générateur celui d'une organisation
terroriste qui depuis 2 7 pratique la
tyrannie compris contre le peuple
qu'elle est censé représenter Israël a
le droit et le devoir absolu d'éliminer
cette émanation sanguinaire de l'dre
islamiste qui est le
Hamas j'ai entendu ce matin les mots du
président de la République madame la
Première ministre visant à créer une
coalition internationale à l'instar de
celle qui existe contre daesh madame la
Première ministre nous avons besoin de
précision sur cette annonce son
périmètre exact et sur son
opérationnalité les actes qui ont été
commis par le Hamas sont souvent
qualifiés d'indiscibl mais pour moi ils
doivent être nommé de manière très
claire ces monstruosités constituent les
pires horreurs que le monde est connu
depuis les années 1990 durant lesquelles
EUR lieu le génocide rwandais ou le
massacre de seranita ici c'est l'acte
génocidaire le plus important contre le
peuple juif depuis la choie et le temps
des pougromes et les milliers de civils
palestiniens mort en raison des
représaille israélienne contre le Hamas
sont aussi
insupportables toute vie sacrifiée est
un drame pour l'humanité tout crime
contre l'humanité mérite une réponse
mais la silération ne doit pas nous
paralyser mes chers collègues au
contraire nous devons nous élever et
constituer de véritables remparts contre
les forces obscurantistes car le Hamas
n'est pas une représentation politique
c'est une organisation terroriste qui
vise l'islamisation totale en détruisant
notre modèle de société il cherche non
pas exterminé l'État d'Israël mais
exterminé tout juif comme toute personne
qui n'accepterait pas de se soumettre à
sa loi pour vous convaincre lisez ou
relisez les 36 articles de la Charte du
Hamas aucune solution politique n'est
envisageable avec une telle organisation
qui refuse toute forme de négociation
diplomatique après les attentats de
Paris ou de Nice notre lutte contre
daesh comporte bien des similitudes avec
la situation présente
et pourtant pour les civils pour les
otages il faut avoir du courage avec
pour seul mot d'ordre pacifier protéger
obtenir un cesser lefeu humanitaire ou à
défaut assurer un couloir humanitaire
solide nous supposons que c'est l'objet
du déplacement du président de la
République même si nous aurions préféré
madame la Première ministre que cette
nécessaire visite puisse se dérouler
après la fin du débat au Parlement
croyant à la parole de la France nous
espérons ne pas être déçu par les
résultats effectifs de cette visite le
Hamas nous replonge dans l'horreur et
dans toute la noirceur de la guerre
ravivant la mémoire des pires épisodes
de notre histoire comme daesh le
Hezbollah le Djihad islamique al-qïda ou
bokoaram le Hamas est l'un des bras
armés d'une conquête internationale au
profit d'un régime totalitaire c'est la
résurgence cela été dit par mon collègue
grotillot du mouvement islamiste qui
parvient à se réinventer chaque jour
avec les soutiens que sont le Qatar ou
l'Iran Israël ne nous trompons pas
queles que soi nos réserves sur les
moyens militaires utilisés représente
actuellement le premier bouclier contre
ce projet politique liberticide et vient
d'être à nouveau malheureusement la
première victime de ce projet en ce
moment j'ai une pensée pour nos
compatriotes le bilan est terrible les
victimes françaises aujourd'hui recensé
sont au nombre de 30 au moins et de
disparus et otage
présumé jamais autant de Français n'ont
été victimes du terrorisme depuis les
terribles attentats de Nice en
2016 pour autant ne faisons pas
d'amalgame mes chers collègues dans
notre pays les partisans de la création
d'un État islamique ne sont qu'une
extrême minorité et pourtant chaque acte
terroriste est un traumatisme à juste
titre national je tiens à le rappeler à
le souligner dans cette période où les
tensions communautaires sont exacerbées
le conflit en cours au Proche Orient ne
doit pas s'importer sur notre territoire
comme un conflit entre religions notre
responsabilité en tant que politique est
de veiller à ce qu'aucune discrimination
aucun amalgame ne soit admis pas
d'amalgame mais pas d'angélisme non plus
la tolérance zéro doit s'appliquer face
à
l'antisémitisme comme face à toute
discrimination à l'encontre de nos
compatriotes de confession musulmanes le
principe de
notre principe de laïcité qui est au
cœur de notre République impose le
respect et la protection de
l'attachement et l'attachement des
croyants à la Bible au Coran ou à la tor
mais aucun des préceptes de ces livres
sacrés pour ces croyants ne peuvent être
considérés comme supérieur à la loi de
la République Aristide brillant résuma
cela en proclamant et vous le dites
souvent monsieur le Président la loi
protège la foi tant que la foi ne dicte
pas sa loi transiger avec ces principes
c'est affaiblir durablement notre pacte
républicain transiger avec ces principes
c'est faire mourir une deuxè fois Samuel
pati et Dominique Bernard l'assassinat
de ce dernier il y a 11 jours à haras
moins d'une semaines après les attaques
du Hamas témoignent des risques qui
pèsent dans notre pays cet attentat doit
nous alerter sur l'absence de risque
zéro face à la menace terroriste mais
nous oblige également sur notre devoir
de mettre en place des mesures de
protection de prévention la sanction est
nécessaire mais quels sont nos moyens de
lutter contre la radicalisation
notamment chez les jeunes exclure des
élèves de nos établissements scolaires
pour comportement inacceptabl lors de la
minute de silence à la mémoire de
Dominique Bernard bien sûr mais j'ai
envie de dire et
après la prévention du poison
totalitaire qui infecte des cerveaux
perméables à cette idéologie mortifère
doit être au cœur de notre action
républicaine mes chers collègues s'il
existe des proies dans nos villes et nos
quartiers c'est qu'il existe aussi des
prédateurs et n'oublions jamais que 75 %
des attentats islamistes commis sur
notre territoire l'ont été par des
Français notre République ne peut
s'accommoder de devoir protéger des
compatriotes du fait même de leur
religion érigé en
identité le faire bien évidemment pour
des rais on évidente de sécurité c'est
néanmoins reconnaître en creux que notre
pacte républicain et notre principe du
vivre ensemble sont menacés voire
nier c'est la même chose lorsqu'on
s'attaque à l'un de nos compatriotes
parce qu'il est professeur et qu'il
représente notre institution nationale
porteuse d'émancipation et en charge
d'éclairer de forger les esprits
critiques les semeurs de terreur ont
horreur de nos lumières de la démocratie
de la laïcité de la liberté l'expression
ou encore du droit absolu des femmes à
disposer de leur corps j'en reviens pour
terminer à la situation du conflit
israélo-palestinien depuis 30 ans la
solution à deux états n'est toujours pas
mise en œuvre depuis 95 et l'assassinat
d'itraak Rabin par un ultra nationaliste
israélien l'esprit des accords d'Oslo
n'est qu'un vague souvenir qui se
dissipe progressivement dans les vapeurs
de l'escalade des violences la politique
actuelle du gouvernement israélien n'est
pas exemple de critique la tendance
actuelle est effectivement inquiétante
et répond à une réelle radicalisation
politique à vocation ultra nationaliste
il nous faut condamner avec fermeté les
choix opérés depuis de trop nombreuses
années qui mettent en péril toute
résolution du conflit ces choix
contribuent à exacerber les tensions
empêchent toute perspective pour la
jeunesse palestinienne privé de tout
espoir d'émancipation les réactions
désespérées de cette jeunesse que je
condamne conforte ensuite l'extrême
droite israélienne dans sa politique
d'annexion l'engrenage est sans fin ce
cercle vicieux condamne tout avancé sur
le chemin de la paix et j'aiété horrifié
il y a quelques jours d'entendre sur une
chaîne de radio les mots d'un père
vivant dans un village dirigé par le
rbola dans le Sud Liban ce père venait
de perdre son fils lors d'une une
incursion en Israël et il disait la
Palestine a besoin du sang de ses
martyres des mots qui font peur mais qui
nous oblige à agir en tant que
socialiste nous soutenons la
reconnaissance de deux États souverains
c'est le seul chemin que nous devons
emprunter collectivement les
progressistes Palestiniens comme la
gauche israélienne qui reste puissante
doivent œuvrer dans le sens d'une
résolution durable de ce conflit et il
est de notre rôle de soutenir toute
initiative de leur part nous devons
relayer ces démarches positives appelant
à combattre la surenchère favorisant le
dialogue et apaisant les tensions
intercommunautaires et je pense aux
guerrières de la paix à ce mouvement
womanen wage peace et à tous ces
organismes qui proposent de tisser des
liens et de créer des ponts plutôt que
des murs entre les deux côté ces
militants de la paix sont souvent
combattus férocement par les forces
extrémistes des de camp cela témoigne de
la pertinence de leur combat chers
collègues oui il faut favoriser une
reprise du dialogue pour cela du côté
palestinien une véritable force
démocratique et une construction
politique tournant le dos notamment à la
à la corruption sont nécessaires ne pas
l'encourager ne pas la favoriser
reviendra de fait à fragiliser la
démocratie israélienne sans ses
prérequis aucune négociation n'est
possible pour terminer la France et
l'Europe doivent insuffler une dynamique
nous devons collectivement tout mettre
en œuvre pour installer un climat de
désescalade le rapport sénatorial de
décembre 2022 porté par la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces amé armé du Sénat et son
président de l'époque que je salue
Christian Cambon était très inspirante
tant dans son diagnostic que dans la
perspective et dans les recommandations
après s'être rendu sur place le but des
auteurs du rapport était de s'interroger
sur les chance de reprise d'un dialogue
autour de la solution à deux états les
conditions d'une nouvelle feuille de
route avaient été clairement définies
dans ce rapport il faut les relire il
faut nous les approprier monsieur le
Président je termine je vous assure en
attendant un retour sur le chemin de la
raison ce sont les peuple d'Israël et de
Palestine qui sont pris en otage une
prise d'otage idéologique aux
conséquences mortifères
ce sont les enfants de ces deux peuples
qui subissent les foudres de la violence
qui seront marqués dans leur chair au
fer rouge de la guerre et pourtant mes
chers collègues ce sont les enfants de
ces deux peuples qui ont la lourde
charge de mettre un terme à cette guerre
sans fin les solutions existent elle
repose sur l'esprit de raison le respect
mutuel et la foi inébranlable en un
avenir de paix Shalom
salam merci monsieur le
président
la parole est au
président non la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Olivier kéic pour le groupe de
l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues plus de 2 semaines après
les attaques meurtrières du Hamas sur le
territoire israélien qui ont fait plus
de 1400 morts nous sommes toujours
profondément
choqués je tiens avant tout au nom du
groupe Union centriste avoir une pensée
pour toutes les victimes innocentes
parmi elles nous déplorons 30
compatriotes tués nous comptons toujours
également neu français portés disparus
dont une jeune femme qui a le statut
d'otage nous soutenons les efforts du
gouvernement pour obtenir en priorité la
libération de tous les otages notre
groupe exprime sa compassion aux blessés
aux familles des victimes aux proches
des otages enlevés qui vivent dans
l'angoisse nous pensons aussi à toutes
les victimes civiles qu'ell soi en
Israël et à Gaza et à tous ceux qui sont
désormais dans la
souffrance nous imaginions avoir commu
connu des sommets de monstruosités avec
les attentats d'Al-Qaïda du 11 septembre
ou ceux de DAEs le 13 novembre 2015 à
Paris avec les exactions du 7 octobre
dernier en Israël le Hamas
s'inscrit dans cette barbare compétition
des organisations terroristes islamistes
il a enchaîné massacre de masse acte de
torture d'une cruauté bestiale mais
aussi enlèvement de plus de 200 civils
aujourd'hui séquestrés les mots
demeurent impuissant face à
l'ignominie nous condamnons cette
organisation terroriste et ses actes
avec force Israël est en droit de se
défendre et de chercher à éliminer le
Hamas qui a pour objectif lui-même de
faire disparaître l'État hébreux de la
carte dans un premier temps car ne nous
y trompons pas le Hamas tout comme daesh
ou al-qïda vivent dans la haine de nos
valeurs et vivent visent la destruction
à terme de la civilisation occidentale
les attentats d'aras et Bruxelles qui
ont suivi nous l'ont douloureusement
rappelé on comprend dès lors pourquoi le
président de la République a pu proposer
aujourd'hui à Jérusalem que la coalition
internationale actuellement déployé en
Irak et en Syrie pour lutter contre
l'État islamique puisse aussi lutter
contre le Hamas la population
palestinienne de Gaza est aussi l'otage
de cette organisation terroriste qui
mène ses attaques militaires depuis des
installations civiles rien ne serait
pire que de vouloir confondre le Hamas
avec la cause palestinienne et sa
légitime revendication à disposer d'un
État autonome le Hamas a franchi une
ligne rouge pour qu'Israël ne puisse
plus accepter le moindre accord dès lors
quelle solution adopter pour Israël à
Gaza déplacer le Hamas au Qatar ou les
Palestiniens vers l'Égypte ou la
Jordanie impossible aucun exat ne
l'accepterait faire une barrière avec
une démarcation large de plusieurs
kilomètres é miné à l'image de la
démarcation entre les deux Corées ce
serait condamner la population de Gaza à
la misère et à laisser la haine grandir
en attendant la prochaine éruption
bombarder la bande de gaz de Gaza
indistinctement en exposant toute la
population palestinienne c'est le piège
tendu par le Hamas qui veut réussir là
où daesh a échoué et nous souhaitons que
la démocratie israélienne combattent en
respectant le droit international
humanitaire mais tout le monde voit bien
la difficulté car les terroristes se
cachent dans la population elle-même une
difficulté supplémentaire pour le
gouvernement israélien vient de ce que
l'organisation terroriste a le soutien
de l'Iran la déclaration récente du
ministre des Affaires étrangères
iraniens appelant à éradiquer les Juifs
et arrayer Israël de la carte en est une
nouvelle illustration elle vient
rejoindre en tout point la doctrine du
Hamas la Russie jubile la Chine et le
banquier de
l'attelage vous remarquerez que pour ces
trois états Iran Russie ou Chine le
Hamas n'est pas une organisation
terroriste
la situation est très préoccupante si
Israël bombarde Gaza et élimine
effectivement le Hamas qui gérera Gaza
en ruine que deviendra alors ce qui sera
un immense bidonville comment éviter que
toute la jeunesse palestinienne ne tombe
à son tour dans le panneau des sirènes
du Hamas avec l'effondrement de
l'Autorité palestinienne en Cisjordanie
comment ne pas craindre l'escalade
régionale avec le Hezbollah proxy de
l'Iran qui non content d'étrangler le
Liban est susceptible de plonger le pays
du sèdre à nouveau dans un conflit avec
son voisin hier j'assistais à la prise
d'armes aux Invalides présidé par le
ministre des Armées Sébastien le Cornu à
l'occasion des 40 ans de l'attentat du
dracar à beyouth où 58 militaires
français ont perd ont perdu la vie ne
les oublions pas 700 militaires français
sont déployés dans le cadre de la force
intérimaire des Nations Unies au Liban
la frontière avec Israël il serait alors
en première ligne d'une reprise des
hostilités ne l'oublions pas le rapport
du président Cambon et de la commission
des affaires étrangères intitulé Israël
Palestine redonner un horizon politique
au processus de paix avait anticipé il y
a un peu moins d'un an l'embrasement que
nous déplorons
aujourd'hui la formation du gouvernement
de monsieur netanahou qui allie la
droite avec une extrême droite composé
de suprémacistes Juifs tenant d'une
idéologie expansionniste et visant un
État théocratique soumis à la loi
religieuse menace les fondements de la
démocratie israélienne il pose un
problème de morale et de conscience que
les manifestations hebdomadaires dans
l'État hébreu ont révélé de nombreux
articles de presse ont sonné l'alarme
dans une tribune du Monde du 9 février
sophie Bessis écrivait suite à la
sanglante attaque d'une synagogue de de
semaines plus tôt d'un côté les
provocations délibérées de ministres
israéliens pressé de montrer aux
Palestiniens de quel côté se situe la
force de l'autre la monté d'un désespoir
mortifère devant la dégradation des
conditions de vie en sis-jordanie et
l'absence de toute perspective de paix
dans la justice ont conduit à
l'explosion actuelle si rien n'est fait
elle risque de prendre des proportions
que nul ne parviendra à contenir fin de
citation une addition de haine n'a
jamais donné un bon résultat pour les
peuples il est majeur de se consacrer
dès maintenant à la paix l'escalade de
violence en territoire
israélo-palestinien vient nous rappeler
que la solution à deux états un État
d'Israël et un État palestinien est la
seule solution viable pour la paix je me
réjouis que le Président de la
République soit aujourd'hui à telavive
pour reprendre l'initiative politique et
réaffirmer une exigence que le général
de gale éfoquait déjà de façon
visionnaire lors de sa conférence de
presse du 27 novembre 1967 mais il est
vrai que les accords d'Abraham ont
permis des avancées majeures auprès des
pays du Golf ils ont apporté une
nouvelle dynamique de normalisation
israélo-arabe comme président du groupe
d'amitié francepays du golf je n'ai pu
que m'en féliciter ces avancées très
concrètes se sont traduites par de
réelles coopération sécuritaires et
militaire comme j'avais pu le souligner
en mai 2022 lors d'un colloque que j'ai
accueilli au Sénat en compagnie du
président Roger carouci
mais si les accords d'Abraham ont
vocation à promouvoir la paix aux
frontières d'Israël tous mes
interlocuteurs du golf m'ont toujours
affirmé que la résolution du conflit
israël-palestinien restait une priorité
pour emporter l'adhésion de leur
population en ne s'alignant pas sur les
États-Unis en 2003 dans son intervention
en Irak la France a prouvé son
indépendance au MoyenOrient la France
est un tiers de confiance naturelle pour
amorcer un nouveau dialogue et un nouvel
horizon au processus de paix notre pays
a soutenu sans discontinuer le droit
d'Israël à exister et à vivre du en
sécurité d'une part la création d'un
État palestinien vivant dans des
frontières sûres est reconnu d'autre
part il est vital pour tous d'abandonner
la stratégie de la céité volontaire et
du dénis de réalité à l'égard de la
réalité palestinienne pour Israël cela
consistera à abandonner sa stratégie de
colonisation en sis-jordanie et à
Jérusalem Est pour la Palestine cela
signifie la fixation d'un calendrier
démocratique avec des garanties de
déroulement des scrutins en sisjordanie
Gaza Jérusalem est la France doit être
l'aiguillon afin que l'Europe mette en
place un nouveau dialogue entre Israël
et Palestine l'Union a débloqué 200
millions d'euros d'aide aux Palestiniens
avant le conflit elle doit maintenant
investir le volet politique en plus du
volet humanitaire je salue le rôle de
l'Égypte qui a autorisé le passage d'une
aide humanitaire vers Gaza après de
longues journées de fermure du
post-frontière il faut en effet porter
secours au civil Gazaoui qui manque de
produits de première nécessité la
décision d'une aide supplémentaire de 10
millions d'euros portés par la France
mérite d'être souligné vendredi un vol
spécial conv voira du fret médical une
fois de plus la France répond présente
et les sénateurs centristes soutiennent
cette initiative être en empathie avec
les personnes qui souffrent et provoquer
la désescalade par la promotion de la
paix pour apporter l'espoir d'une vie
dans la sécurité et la inité au
prochariant telle est la démarche
d'apaisement qui je l'espère sera portée
avec succès par le président la
République je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Nicole Duranton pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole ma cher collègue merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collèges cèg nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour évoquer la situation
grave et les tragédies qui se déroulent
actuellement au Proche Orient région qui
est le théâtre de défis de tension et de
conflits persistants depuis près de 75
ans par sa résolution 181 du 29 novembre
1947 l'Assemblée générale des Nations
unies adopte le plan de partage de la
Palestine posant le principe de la
création de de États souverains et
indépendants en
1948 l'État d'Israël a été créé et le
conflit israélo-palestinien est né il y
a eu des guerres israélo arabes puis la
guerre du Kipour il y a eu ensuite une
première Intifada en
1987 les accords d'Oslo de
1993 appelant à une solution à deux
états sont venus apporter un vent
d'espoir malheureusement il s'agit d'un
processus
inachevé depuis l'histoire du conflit se
poursuit elle est rythmée par de
multiples épisodes de tension plus ou
moins aigu et plus ou moins long le
dernier rate est survenu il y a 3
semaines quand les terroristes du Hamas
et du Djihad islamique ont attaqué le
peuple israélien il s'agit d'une
séquence nouvelle dans un conflit qui ne
s'est jamais éteint pour reprendre les
mots du politologue trad mais ces
événements sont inédits par la nature de
leur violence depuis plusieurs semaines
nous sommes les témoins de nouvelles
images d'une barbarie sans précédent
nous sommes nombreux à exprimer notre
colère notre notre bouleversement face à
la tragédie qui se déroule sous nos yeux
les adjectifs ne sont pas assez forts
pour dénoncer ces atrocités le groupe
RDPI soutient le peuple israélien
condamne sans détour et avec la plus
grande fermeté ces ces attaques
terroristes nous le martellerons jamais
assez rien ne justifie le terrorisme
nulle part ni jamais cela est une
évidence sauf pour certains pourtant
notre pays a été frappé de nombreuses
fois par le terrorisme et
l'obscurantisme cela a encore été le cas
récemment avec l'assassinat de Dominique
Bernard à
haras la présence du président de la
République en Israël aujourd'hui est un
témoignage du soutien entier et sincère
que la France porte à l'égard d'Israël
il prend racine dans l'amitié profonde
et ancienne qui lit notre nation au
peuple israélien nous avons également
une pensée pour le peuple palestinien
pris en étau entre les terroristes du
Hamas et l'armée israélienne vous avez
raison Madame la première ministre les
Palestiniens ne sont pas le Hamas et le
Hamas n'est pas le peuple
palestinien en juin 2022 je me suis
rendu en Israël à Gaza et en
sixisjordanie avec des collègues
sénateurs de la commission des Affaires
étrangère de la défense et des forces
armées sous la présidence de Christian
Cambon que je salue cette mission avait
pour thème l'avenir du du processus de
paix au Proche Orient nous avions
ressenti alors une très forte tension à
Gaza et à Hébron et perçu le danger que
représentait l'absence de pers
dans notre rapport de 12 recommandations
la délégation avait estimé que la
solution à deux états restait la seule
voix acceptable et crédiible à condition
de redonner un horizon politique et un
agenda au processus de paix la seule à
même de répondre aux aspirations
légitimes des Israéliens et des
Palestiniens à la sécurité
l'indépendance et à la reconnaissance à
la dignité malheureusement un an as
après la situation s'est dégradée de
plus en plus et a fini par s'embraser et
cela nous l'avions ressenti aujourd'hui
le Hamas et le Djihad islamique
anéantissent les espoirs et les
aspirations légitimes de ces deux
peuples à vivre en paix les terroristes
balaient tous les efforts menés pour une
pour bâtir une paix durable et il le
siment que la désolation et la mort le
Hamas doit être éradiqué le terroriste
n'a pas trop n'a pas de frontières notre
pays se retrouve une nouvelle fois
endeuillé le bilan est lourd pour nos
compatriotes nous retenons notre souffle
en espérant que les Français portés
disparus soient retrouvés sains et SAU
et sauve depuis Israël notre président
de la République adresse un message fort
aux Français victime de ce conflit ainsi
qu'à leur famillees depuis 3 semaines la
population civile retenue dans les zones
de conflit est en proie à de nombreux
périls dangers mortel de la guerre
manque de nourriture et de médicaments
il faut éviter une nouvelle dégradation
de la situation humanitaire madame la
Première ministre comme vous l'avez
rappelé hier à l'Assemblée nationale la
porte de Rafa doit être ouverte
quotidiennement et en permanence pour
permettre aux habitants de la bande de
Gaza de recevoir l'aide humanitaire
international celle-ci doit être
renforcée à l'exemple de la France qui
augmente de 10 millions d'euros l'aide
destinée au
Gazaoui nous ne sommes pas en train
d'assister à une guerre conventionnelle
il ne s'agit pas d'un conflit opposant
deux armées régulières Israël a le droit
de se défendre contre ces attaques
terroristes toutefois sa riposte ne peut
se faire en contradiction avec ses
obligations de respecter le droit
international et notamment le droit
international humanitaire le respect du
droit et le devoir des démocrat e à
l'heure où le hzbollah Libanais et
l'Iran menace d'ouvrir un second front
au nord de l'État hébreu nous devons
tout mettre en œuvre en faveur d'une
désescalade de la violence au proches
Orient c'est également dans ce but que
le Président de la République est
présent en Israël la situation
géopolitique actuelle du Proche Orient
ne se limite pas au seul territoire
palestinien et israélien sur lequel le
monde entier a les yeux rivés l'Iran a
menacé Israël de mener une action
préventive à son encontre des menaces
ont été proférées à l'encontre de
soldats américains ce contexte nous
laisse craindre la multiplication des
foyers de conflits et de guerres dans
tout le proche Ori Orient et même
au-delà il faut éviter un embrasement
général madame la Première ministre vous
avez dit dans cette émicyquele que la
France est un artisan de la paix comme
vous et avec vous nous sommes convaincus
que la France tient un rôle important au
côté de ses alliés pour mettre fin à ce
conflit les déclarations du président de
la République ce jour en témoigne comme
l'a déclaré notre ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères lors de la
conférence ducer pour la paix samedi
dernier la seule solution viable est la
solution à deux états elle seule peut
permettre au peuple israélien et au
peuple palestinien de vivre dans un
climat de paix et de sécurité madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues nous
devons aujourd'hui nous unir derrière la
bannière commune de la paix nous devons
rappeler au monde entier que le seul
combat qui doit être mené est celui pour
la paix comme le disait le président de
la République Raymond Point Carré la
paix est une création continue
continuons donc d'en être l'artisan je
vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
la Présidente Cécile cucerman pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyens
et
écologistes madame la Présidente vous
avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues rien ne justifie l'horreur du
samedi 7 octobre
2023 à l'heure où le soleil se lève la
barbarie s'est exprimée sur Israël une
barbarie qui est le fruit de la volonté
du Hamas se revendique en lui-même de
ses actes terroristes islamiques des
morts des blessés des
otages ils étaient des enfants des
femmes des hommes qui demandaient qu'à
vivre ils ont été sauvagement exécutés
violentés bless blessés meurtris à
jamais pris en otage ce 7 octobre était
pourtant celui de Simat t littéralement
joie de la torora pour longtemps le
bruit des actes terroristes ont fait
taire le son de la joie les
revendications du hamass sont claires
tuer du Juif nous renvoyant un
antisémisme assumé
multiséculaire au Proche Orient comme
partout dans le monde la douleur du
peuple israélien est profonde et nous
nous y
associons depuis ce samedi 7 octobre
l'engrenage à la violence s'amplifie
heure par heure nous ne pouvons accepter
que l'État d'Israël que le gouvernement
de Monsieur netanahou passe du droit à
se défendre à un droit de se venger et
je fais mien ici les mots de Dominique
de Villepin qui affirmé il y a bientôt
15 jours le droit à la légitime défense
n'est pas un droit à une vengeance
indiscriminée un mort est un mort quel
que soit son ethnie sa croyance nous
nous refuserons toujours à les trier à
les
opposer la situation de Gaza n'est ni
acceptable ni soutenable déplacement
d'un million de population tir de
missile quasi en continu faisant jour
après jour des centaines de morts
supplémentaires cette situation n'est ni
acceptable ni soutenable pour pour le
peuple Gazaoui qui est aujourd'hui privé
des biens humains indispensables ce sont
2 millions de personnes qui sont privées
d'eau potable obligeant une partie
d'entre elles à boire de l'eau de mer
nocive à leur santé à cela s'ajoute un
manque de nourriture de carburant
d'électricité toutes les organisations
le disent ce sont plusieurs centaines de
camions quotidiens qui sont
indispensables pour assurer la survie
aux 2 millions d'habitants loin des 20
camionons d'aide humanitaire autorisé à
circuler actuellement cette situation
n'est ni acceptable ni soutenable pour
le peuple israélien lui-même car
l'appauvrissement la survie imposée aux
habitants et nous le savons toutes et
tous un des terraau des organisations
terroristes islamiques et de la
radicalisation à venir d'une partie de
la population enfin cette situation
n'est ni acceptable ni soutenable
internationalement car se joue en ce
moment l'avenir pour plusieurs décennies
de la sécurité au ProcheOrient et dans
le monde oui nous devons combattre la
guerre qui se déroule sous nos yeux la
France doit faire entendre sa voix
diplomatique et elle doit surtout jouer
un rôle indispensable pour cesser cette
guerre il n'y a pas de oui mais comme
nous l'entendons depuis plusieurs jours
il y a le respect du droit international
le respect des différentes résolutions
de l'ONU qui à soit je le redis la
création de deux États mais aussi la fin
de l'occupation et de la colonisation ce
respect est une condition fondamentale à
la paix de cette volonté de paix
incarnée en
1984 par le prix Nobel de la Paix remis
conjointement à Yasser Arafat Shimon
Perez et itsac Rabine ce dernier le paya
de sa vie l'année suivante exécuté par
l'extrême droite is israélienne qui ne
voulait pas de la paix alors oui
aujourd'hui des actes forts doivent être
pris par la France nous saluons le
déplacement du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron en Israël et
en sisjordanie car si le met sépare le
ha nous rassemble cependant madame la
ministre nous sommes surpris des propos
du président de ce jour pouvant laisser
entendre un nouvel engagement militaire
de la France dans le cadre d'une
extension du champ d'intervention de la
coalition internationale contre daesh si
cela devait se confirmer
inévitablement un débat et un vote au
Parlement serait indispensable au-delà
de ces propos et de ce déplacement il
nous faut aller plus loin la France doit
être à l'initiative d'une nouvelle
résolution à l'ONU qui porte l'exigence
du cesser le feu et le respect des
résolutions précédentes la France doit
pouvoir redire à l'état israélien que la
de Marwan bargouti nécessaire car il est
aujourd'hui reconnu par beaucoup en
Israël comme en Palestine comme un de
ceux qui peuvent être un homme de
dialogue entre palestinien et israélien
enfin et
surtout la France doit au-delà des mots
réellement s'attaquer au Hamas je le
redis le Hamas ne peut pas être pour les
progressiste que nous sommes l'avenir du
peuple palestinien la barbarie du 7
octobre dernier le démontre aux yeux du
monde entier ces liens avec le djihad
islamiste et d'autres le placent
factuellement dans le camp des ennemis
de la liberté ces dernières années peu
nombreuses étaient les voies pour
dénoncer ses agissements pour renforcer
le contrôle de l'utilisation des aides
internationales et européennes à
destination du peuple palestinien et
c'est dans un silence assourdissant que
le Hamas a assis sa domination sur Gaza
ces dernières années affaiblissant par
la même le poids de l'Autorité
palestinienne alors soyons ferm en tout
point et reconnaissons-le ce n'est pas
la destruction de Gaza qui affaiblira le
Hamas ses premiers dirigeants sont
actuellement au Qatar et si nous voulons
réellement agir cessons nos relations
diplomatiques invitons les autres pays à
le
faire pour réellement s'attaquer à cette
organisation qui a plongé comme je le
disais le monde dans un temps que nous
pensions révolu oui les auteurs comme
les instigateurs de ces attentats
devront être traduits devant les
juridictions internationales et jugé par
celle-ci je veux pour finir madame la
Première ministre redire que nous
demandons avec force et détermination un
cess lefeu immédiat le CESS lefeu que
nous exigeons et pour lequel nous vous
demandons madame la Première ministre
d'agir n'est pas le maintien de la
situation actuelle il doit mettre fin au
massacre civil il doit permettre la
libération de tous les otages il doit
permettre de construire la sécurité
indispensable à tous les peuples du
Proche Orient nous savons tous ici que
sans cesser le feu immédiat c'est
malheureusement et très certainement
l'embrasement de tout le Proche Orient
qui se prépare personne ne domine la
guerre et personne ne sait au profit de
qui elle se termine madame la Première
ministre la France n'est pas seule elle
est attendue par de nombreux habitants
d'Israël et de Palestine qui veulent
simplement mais légitimement vivre en
paix pouvoir sortir écouter de la
musique voir grandir leurs enfants je
veux saluer ici ces habitants de Haifa
et de nazarth et d'ailleurs qui se
regroupe au-delà de leurs origines pour
assurer que leurs villes leur territoire
ne sombre pas dans des affrontements
entre communauté qui seraient mortifère
pour leurs habitants depuis cette
tribune du Sénat de la République França
16 je veux enfin dire aux enfants
d'Israël et de Palestine que nous ne les
oublions pas nous serons toujours dans
le camp de ceux qui veulent agir pour
leur permettre de vivre grandir heureux
et ainsi voir chaque jour le soleil se
lever Jean joress affirma avec force
l'affirmation de la paix et le plus
grand des combats je souhaite avec mon
groupe qu'il devienne le combat de nous
tous merci madame la
Présidente la parole
est au président Claude maluré pour le
groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoire vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre messieurs les
ministres je ne peux commencer cette
intervention sans condamné comme tous
ceux qui m'ont précédé l'effroyable
massacre par le Hamas le 7 octobre
dernier sans dénoncer aussi ceux qui
chez nous refuse de le
condamner sans exprimer notre compassion
et notre solidarité envers ses victimes
et sans avoir une pensée
particulière pour nos compatriotes
assassinés et pour ceux retenus
aujourd'hui en
otage mais quelle que soit notre colère
et quelle que soit notre douleur nous
avons un devoir le devoir de comprendre
pour
agir il y aura un avant et un après le 7
octobre
2023 comme il y a eu un avant et un
après le 11 septembre 2001 et un avant
et un après le 24 février 2022 touche
par touche le visage du monde actuel se
dessine le 20e siècle a vu la lutte à
mort des démocraties contre les
totalitarismes que nous avions cru avoir
gagné à jamais le jour de la chute du
mur de Berlin le 11 septembre 2001 a
révélé comme un coup de Tenon que les
démocraties même la plus puissante
étaient vulnérabl le 24 février 2022 a
vu se reformer l'international des
dictateurs contre le monde libre Russie
Chine Corée du Nord Iran allié dans la
guerre contre l'Ukraine contre l'Europe
et l'ordre du monde libéral le 7 octobre
2020 23 a vu les mêmes quatre a vu les
mêmes quatre cavaliers de l'Apocalypse
des dictatures solidairire dans le refus
de dénoncer le terrorisme islamiste il a
vu aussi le reste du monde ne plus
choisir son camp comme au siècle
précédent mais se déterminé au gré de
ses intérêts le monde bipolaire du 20e
siècle a vécu le monde unipolaire des 30
dernières années aussi celui
d'aujourd'hui voit le retour de
l'affrontement des démocraties et des
dictatures mais dans un univers
multipolaire où rien n'est joué d'avance
et dans ce monde nouveau il ne faut pas
se le cacher les démocraties ont perdu
beaucoup de terrain en 30
ans mais la partie est loin d'être jouée
et il faut d'abord tordre le coup à une
propagande mensongère qui fait floress
grâce à la simplicité de son slogan et à
la sous-intelligentia des
pseudoexerts le sud global n'existe pas
loin d'être global ce soi-disant Sud est
parfaitement divisé
une dizaine de pays africains d'Amérique
latine et surtout l'Inde un 6e de
l'humanité à elle seule ont partagé les
condamnations des Occidentaux contre le
Hamas beaucoup d'autres n'ont pas pris
position parce qu'ils pensent que entre
guillemets ce n'est pas leur guerre ou
parce qu'ils craignent la fin de la
sécurité de leur approvisionnement
pétrolier ce Sud global allié au
dictateur c'est le rêve de
l'International des tyrans comme le
mouvement des Non Alignés était la
marionnette de l'URSS mais c aujourd'hui
qu'un rêve notre responsabilité
historique et de faire en sorte qu'il ne
devienne pas réalité parce qu'alors le
21e siècle se transformerait en
cauchemar on peut disserter sans fin des
réseaux qui ont poussé le Hamas à cet
effroyable massacre elles sont
nombreuses mais il en est une qui domine
toutes les autres anéantir les accords
d'Abraham et si les mains qui ont égorgé
les enfants israéliens viennent de Gaza
le cerveau qui a conçu ce plan atroce et
machavel est
attéérant la première des réactions à
l'étranger et il faut l'en créditer a
été celle de Joe Biden qui n'a pas
hésité à traverser deux fois
l'Atlantique en 24 heures pour
s'entretenir en tête à-tête avec ses
alliés israéliens et tenter sans succès
pour l'heure de rencontrer les
dirigeants arabes
modérés seul quelques phrases en langue
de bois ont fait l'objet d'un communiqué
de sa rencontre avec le Premier ministre
israélien mais il n'estit pas besoin
d'être spécialiste de géopolitique pour
voir ce qu'a vraiment dit le président
des États-Unis le 11 septembre 2001 a
été pour le peuple américain le même
choc que le 7 octobre pour le peuple
israélien la colère et la soif de
vengeance nous ont conduit à deux
erreurs majeures l'invasion de
l'Afghanistan dont nous sommes repartis
20 ans plus tard aussi humiliés qu'au
Vietnam et l'invasion de l'Irak qui a
embrasé tout le Moyen-Orient et qui a eu
comme conséquence le pire qui pouvait
arriver la création de daesh c'est
exactement ce que souhaitait Ben Laden
nous continuerons inlassablement de vous
aider à assurer l'existence et la
sécurité d'Israël mais ne commettez pas
la même erreur ce conseil au lendemant
même des attentats abominables du Hamas
qui ne peuvent conduire qu'à un désir de
vengeance indiscriminée était sans doute
l'un des plus difficiles que Joe Biden a
donné sa vie et les Alliés indéfectibles
d'Israël que sont les Américains étaient
sans doute les mieux placés pour le
donner mais c'est aussi le seul conseil
qui puisse per mettre demain de faire
échouer le plan du Hamas et de l'Iran en
tentant de sauver les accords d'Abraham
les Européens l'ont relayé et c'est
aujourd'hui le président français qui
délivrera le même
message la nature de l' riposte de Saal
montrera si ces conseils ont porté leur
fruit et si Israël parviendra à
distinguer la population palestinienne
des terroristes qui la prennent en otage
depuis 20 ans et dans ce monde où seul
les images comptent a montré au monde
qu'il le fait ce sera effroyablement
difficile ne parlons même pas de la
situation des otages du risque de guerre
au nord avec le hzbollah et pire avec
l'Iran il faudra résoudre ensuite une
question essentielle quelles sont les
options à moyen terme aucune ne semble
pour l'UR crédible l'occupation est
impossible dans la durée le maintien du
Hamas au pouvoir est inacceptable le
remplacer par son rival le fata est
tenable une force d'interposition arabe
est inenvisageable et un gouvernement
fantoche est
inimaginable une guerre totale contre le
peuple palestinien et pas uniquement
contre le Hamas outre qu'elle serait
contraire au droits humanitair ruinerait
la détente amorcée par les accords
d'Abraham avec ses voisins bahraag les
Émirats barabunis le Maroc et
potentiellement l'Arabie Saoudite cette
détente est le seul espoir d'un moyen-
Orient apaisé et concentré sur son
développement économique plutôt que sur
l'affrontement des idéologies et des
guerres de religion elle vient de subir
un coup terrible et l'échec du sommet
pour la paix entre arabe et européens
qui vient d'avoir lieu au CER n'incite
pas à
l'optimisme à long terme la seule façon
d'éradiquer le terrorisme islamiste et
pour Israël et ses partenaires arabes de
trouver le chemin de la stabilité et un
jour de la paix parvenir à une
coexistence pacifier avec ses voisins
n'est pas un choix pour Israël mais une
obligation ceci suppose de résoudre
enfin le problème non résolu depuis
toutes ces années comment réussir la
cohabitation de deux peuples qui vivent
sur cette même partie du monde et qui
resteront les accords d'Abraham avaient
commencé d'apporter une pierre à cet
édifice de paix la prise en compte de
l'avenir des palestinien qui constitue
la tâche aveugle de ces accords doit les
compléter si l'on veut que le
Moyen-Orient ne repartent pas pour 20 ou
30 ans de guerre identiqu aux 75 ans qui
se sont écoulés depuis
1947 les massacres du 7 octobre semblent
nous éloigner pour longtemps d'une telle
réponse mais l'histoire est fait de
surprise et le vertige d'un nouvel
embrasement dont les conséquences
seraient dramatiques peut peut-être
faire retrouver le chemin de la raison
c'est à cette très fragile espérance que
notre pays doit s'emplayer je vous
remercie monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant au
président Guillaume Gontard pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Madame la premère premire ministre le 7
octobre dernier le Hamas a frappé Israël
et son peuple avec une violence abjecte
lors de cet attentat terroriste plus de
1400 personnes ont été massacrées plus
de 3000 ont été blessé avec une barbarie
qui a choqué les esprits et révulser les
cœurs aux quatre coins du monde aux
quatre coins du monde nous pleurons les
victimes israéliennes mais aussi plus de
100 personnes représentant 38
nationalités dont une trentaine de nos
compatriotes nous déplorons aussi plus
de 200 aut
dont nous appelons à la libération
immédiate qu'il me soit permis de
réitérer à cette tribune notre
condamnation la plus ferme de ces
atrocités notre soutien plein et entier
au peuple d'Israël et à ses amis à
travers le monde le 7 octobre 2023 est
déjà entré dans les livres d'histoire
l'une de ces dates charnières que les
élèves apprendront par cœur comme le
jour où l'engrenage s'est enclenché et
le piège du Hamas s'est refermé à
l'horreur de la barbarie du Hamas
a succédé la violente ripose du
gouvernement israélien qui prend la
forme d'une punition collective opérant
un siège destructeur et illégal de la
bande de Gaza noyé sous un tapis de
bombe qui tue indistinctement
combattants et civils toute précaution
prise il ne fait pas de doute que les
victimes civiles se comptent par
milliers don dont de nombreux enfants
notre solidarité s'étend naturellement
au peuple palestinien et à toutes ses
vies fauchées le droit sécurité d'Israël
auquel nous sommes profondément attachés
ne peut exister que dans le respect du
droit international humanitaire ce n'est
pas un droit à une vengeance aussi
aveugle que
contre-productive si la brève histoire
du 21e siècle nous a appris quelque
chose c'est que ne gagne pas les guerres
contre la terreur quand pour se prémunir
ou se venger du terrorisme les
démocraties se rendent coupable de
crimes de guerre et de massacre de
civils elles ne font que renforcer ce
qu'elles cherchent à à anéantir le
terrorisme se nourrit du désespoir et de
la haine s'il est possible de tuer les
combattants du Hamas il n'est pas
possible de tuer une idéologie le combat
contre une idéologie ne peut-être que
politique malheureusement et c'était
l'objectif de l'agresseur c'est la
perspective de résolution politique du
conflit qui a reculé la haine et le
ressentiment sont à leur paroxisme agité
de chaque côté par les partisans de
l'anentissement de l'adversaire qu'il s
appelle Hamas ou extrême droite
messianique ces pourvoyeurs de haine
vitupérants masquent la réalité
structurelle qui n'est certes pas la
réalité de l'instant l'immense majorité
des Palestiniens et des Israéliens
aspire à vivre en paix alors que tsal
prépare une intervention terrestre dans
la bande de Gaza la perspective de paix
ne Sene pas seulement entre Israël et la
Palestine mais pour toute la région
voire au-delà au nord d'Israël les
échanges de tir se multiplient entre le
hzbollah et Saal entraînant ce weekend
les premières menaces à peine voilées de
l'Iran menaces auxquelles la diplomatie
américaine a immédiatement répondu entre
stratégie de dissuasion et perspective
d'un conflit généralisé le le monde vit
dans l'expectative plus que jamais il
est temps de stopper cet engrenage de
violence mortifère qui ne peut
qu'affaiblir davantage nos démocratie
fragile face aux empires autoritaires
ces derniers observent avec intérêt la
dégradation du climat international pour
mener à bien leur propre véléité
expansionniste à commencé par la
tentative à l'œuvre de conquête de
l'Ukraine en conséquence nous demandons
un cesser le feu immédiat et l'arrêt des
combats ces crimes de guerre doivent
cesser une intervention militaire au sol
de tsal dont les objectifs et
l'efficacité sont plus qu'incertains
serait dramatique et extrêmement
coûteuse en vie humaine qu'il s'agisse
de soldats et réservistes israéliens ou
de civils palestiniens il est également
indispensable de massifier
l'intervention humanitaire dans la bande
de Gaza l'ONU estime le besoin à plus de
100 camions par jour nous en sommes très
loin madame la Première ministre si nous
avons entendu une inflexion bienvenue de
votre discours évoquant une trêve
humanitaire le propos du président de la
République ce midi à Tel Aviv nous
inquiète grandement que signifie pour
l'exécutif faire participer la
coopération internationale de lutte
contre DA à la lutte contre le Hamas
s'il s'agit de participer à des
bombardements de la bande de Gaza c'est
parfaitement inacceptable s'il s'agit de
livrer des armes ça allit tout autant
rappelons que les bombardements contre
daesh ont fait entre 1300 sources
officiel et 12000 sources journalistique
victimes civiles dans des territoires
infiniment moins denses que la bande de
Gaza loin de telle véité béliqueuse la
France doit retrouver la voie forte qui
était celle de de Jacques shirac la voix
qui n'hésitait pas à refuser d'engager
nos armées dans une inutile guerre
contre la terreur en Irak la voix qui
étit salué en Palestine comme partout
dans le monde arabe il est indispensable
que la France fasse de nouveau entendre
cette voix et la face raisonnée dans
toute l'Europe depuis trop d'années
l'Europe a fait sien s'agissant du
conflit
israëlo-palestinien le vieux principe
d'Henry cuil il n'y a pas de problème
qu'une absence de solution ne finisse
par résoudre symbole s'il en est de
lâcheté politique ce principe de cuœil
porte pourtant une signification trop
souvent oubliée l'absence de solution
provoquera la solution simpliste du
problème dans la douleur ou la violence
il est déporable que nous en arrivions
là depuis trop d'années nous avons
laissé prospérer le Hamas sur les ruines
du processus de paix anéanti par
l'assassinat d'Isaac Rabine et sur les
ruine de l'Autorité palestinienne
dévitalisée et démonétisée par le zure
du pouvoir la corruption mais surtout
l'absence de toute perspective politique
or sans perspective politique le choix
du peuple palestinien se résume au
suicide à petitfeu ou à l'explosion de
violence je n'ai pas le temps de
reprendre le cours d'une histoire
tumultueuse et complexe de plus de 7
décennies mais nous faisons nôre le
propos et la démonstration magistrale
effectué hier à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale par notre collègue
Jean-Louis bourlange président de la
commission des affaires étrangères il a
tracé le chemin qui pourrait permettre
loin des polémiques à la classe
politique de parler d'une seule voix il
a rappelé que le préalable à tout
processus de paix était l'arrêt et le
reflux de la colonisation illégale qui
depuis deux décennies ghettoïse et
démantelle la sisjordanie dans son
annonce de reprise du processus de paix
le président de la République semble
partager ce constat nous le saluons mais
chat et Chaudé craint le froide nous
nous méfions des grands discours
rarement suivis des faits de notre chef
de l'État au promesses doivent succéder
sans tarder les actes aussi nous
demandons au président de la République
de reconnaître l'état palestinien comme
l'ont déjà fait 138 pays dans le monde
pour construire la paix demain il faudra
un interlocuteur nous souhaitons que la
France pèse de tout son poids pour
organiser une transition démocratique à
la tête de l'Autorité palestinienne pour
ce faire il conviendrait de plaider pour
la libération des prisonniers politique
palestinien notamment ceux à même
d'incarner cette transition et notre
pensée partagée avec de vpin va en
premier lieu vers Marwan bargouti si
Israël et la communauté internationale
sont incapables d'accompagner une telle
transition démocratique alors c'est
toute la sjordanie qui menace de plonger
dans le chaos à la mort de Mahmoud Abbas
occultant tout espoir de paix il est
encore temps d'agir avec force en jouant
une partition différente de celle des
États-Unis par son existence même
l'Union européenne est la preuve par
l'exemple que les ennemis irréductibles
d'hier peuvent devenir les alliés de
demain l'Union doit jouer un rôle
d'arbitre pour construire la paix
condition sinequanon de la sécurité
d'Israël et pour que cesse ce conflit
qui depuis TR qu4 de siècle a engendré
tant de souffrance tant d'humiliation et
emporté tant de vie il est encore temps
d'agir pour la paix une juste cause qui
finira par triompher comme le disait
Isaac Rabine merci merci Monsieur le
présidentard la parole est à madame la
Présidente carer pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 8 minutes madame la
présidente madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le 4 mars 82 le président
François miteran s'exprimait ainsi à
laacné 7 je ne sais pas s'il y a une
réponse acceptable au problème
palestinien mais nul mais nul doute
qu'il n il y a un problème et que non
résolu il pèsera d'un poids tragique et
durable sur cette région du monde quat
décennies plus tard le 7 octobre dernier
Israël a été confronté à ce lourd poids
de la stratégie de la tragédie pardon
les Israéliens ont vécu un drame absolu
l'assassinat aveugle de plus de 1300
personnes par le Hamas essentiellement
des civils dont certains binationaux et
l'enlèvement de près de 200 hommes
femmes et enfants vivant dans le sud
d'Israël les conditions de ce massacre
ont profondément choqué ils ont sidéré
comme j'ai pu le dire dans cet hémicycle
le 11 octobre dernier de telles
atrocités ne laissent pas de place à la
nuance ou à la polémique une nouvelle
fois le groupe RDSE condamne sans
réserve ces attaques terroristes et nous
avons une pensée pour toutes les
victimes et nous pensons également aux
familles françaises touché par cette
tragédie neuf de nos compatriotes
figurent parmi les otages tout doit être
mis mise en œuvre pour les
libérer rien ne peut justifier un tel un
tel acharnement sur des civils une fois
de plus le terrorisme islamique a montré
qu'il était sans égard pour la vie
humaine des attentats de septembre 2001
aux États-Unis à ceux de novembre 2015 à
Paris on pensait avoir vu le pire et
bien non hélas malheureusement aussi
comme on pouvait s'y attendre ce drame
du 7 octobre a conduit à un autre drame
celui que vit en ce moment la population
palestinienne prise sous le feu du tal
dans une dans un Gaza assiégé deux
peuples souffrent aujourd'hui Israël a
riposté pour défendre ses concitoyens
comment pouvait-il en être autrement au
regard de tous ces meurtres impensables
comment ne pas comprendre que ce pays
défend tout simplement son droit à la
sécurité un droit d'autant plus légitime
que les actes du Hamas ont porté le
germe du génocide renvoyant la
population juive à un passé
particulièrement douloureux mais cela
est vrai aussi le le résultat de cet
enchaînement c'est que la souffrance des
Israéliens entraîne la souffrance des
Palestiniens la douleur n'a ni frontière
ni religion du moins pour ceux qui ne
sont pas tombés dans l'abîme de
l'obscurantisme à Gaza cela a été
rappelé on compterait plus de 4000 morts
des centaines de milliers de personnes
déplacées et une situation humanitaire
catastrophique si l'on interroge parfois
sur les buts de la guerre dans un
conflit l'objectif du Hamas é clair SEM
met une discorde irréconciliable entre
Palestiniens et Israéliens pour mieux en
tirer les bénéfices à Gaza et même
au-delà comme on le voit tristement dans
certaines régions du monde où le Hamas
sert des tendards d'une fierté retrouvée
nous le savons les têtes pensantes du
Hamas des autocrates souvent
confortablement installés hors de Gaza
avec la complaisance de certains états
veulent cette escalade parce que le
Hamas est l'ennemi de la paix
parce que le Hamas est l'ennemi du
peuple palestinien parce que le Hamas
parie sur la stratégie du chaos la
communauté internationale doit trouver
les moyens de sortir de ce piège il faut
s'en convaincre et convaincre à terme la
solution n'est certainement pas
militaire on le voit bien la position
d'équilibre est difficile à trouver
entre le droit d'Israël à se défendre et
le respect du droit international en
particulier le respect du droit
international humanitaire le droit de la
guerre c'est une sorte d'oxymor la
réalité de la guerre est bien trop
brutale et reste rarement dans les
règles la communauté internationale
va-t-elle le supporter longtemps alors
que les États-Unis sont un allié
inconditionnel d'Israël nous avons tous
bien entendu le président du message
américain en direction du gouvernement
de Benjamin
netanahou lui disant ne faites pas les
mêmes erreurs que nous après le 11
septembre ne soyez pas consumé par la la
rage c'est bien évidemment difficile à
entendre pour une opinion publique
israélienne traumatisée pourtant la
diplomatie doit rapidement reprendre le
dessus car le risque d'un embrasement
régional plane derrière ce conflit du
Hamas au eszbollah il n'y a qu'un pas et
du hbollah à téran le chemin est court
aussi je salue les efforts de la France
qui est sur tous les fronts au sein de
la communauté internationale et qui
dialogue avec plusieurs pays de la
région vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Première ministre préserver autant que
possible la population civile
palestinienne doit être aussi une
priorité le principe d'une trêve
humanitaire que vous demandez est
naturellement conforme aux valeurs
humanistes que la que la France défend
l'eau la nourriture les médicaments
doivent rentrer à Gaza pour la survie
des victimes du conflit il s'agit aussi
de redonner du sens au droits
humanitaires que j'évoqué à l'instant
sur le le front politique la solution à
deux états refait surface c'est une
bonne chose les accords d'Abraham ont
paru suffire à garantir une sécurité
relative à Israël le Premier ministre
netanahou s'est sans doute bercé
d'illusion avec ses relations de bon
voisinage tout comme il a pensé que
l'affaiblissement de l'Autorité
palestinienne n'était pas si mal le
président de la République entend
défendre cette option qui regagne du
terrain il faut en effet rapidement
combler le vide diplomatique qui s'est
s'est installé autour du conflit
israélo-pestinien de leur côté les
Palestiniens doivent absolument
restaurer sur leur territoire une
autorité politique claire avec la lutte
contre le terrorisme mon groupe partage
cette orientation car ni la terreur ni
la vengeance n'apporteront la paix à
l'évidence ce ne sera pas facile le
sommet pour la paix qui vient tout juste
de se tenir en Égypte le démontre
l'heure n'est pas tout à fait à la
convergence tant l'épée de damoclè de un
assaut israélien dans Gaza pèse lourd
enfin parce que le conflit ce conflit
trouve un écho au-delà du proche- Orient
notre responsabilité en tant qu'élu et
en tant que républicain est de ne pas
faire de la Palestine un enjeu de
solidarité sur notre territoire afin de
ne pas accentuer des fractures déjà
palpables nous devons tenir dans notre
pays un langage de vérité en particulier
auprès des jeunes pour qu'ils gardent la
distance nécessaire et qu'il ne décrypte
pas le monde dans lequel ils vivent au
travers du prisme culturel ou religieux
d'une façon générale ne baissons pas les
bras face à l'obscurantisme où qu'il se
trouve madame la Première ministre nous
serons à vos côtés pour soutenir toutes
les initiatives de la France pour la
paix et la démocratie en 1919 Clémenceau
dans son discours à Verdun soulignait
qu'il était bien plus dur de faire la
paix que de faire la guerre malgré
toutes les embûches la paix doit
toujours rester la première boussole des
peuple gardons ainsi à l'esprit les mots
de
saintexupéri qui disait pour ce qui est
de l'avenir il ne s'agit pas de le
prévoir mais de le rendre possible je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Marie scarer la parole est à
Monsieur Emeric Durox pour la Réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe pour 3
minutes chers
collègues madame la Présidente Mame
madame la Première ministre mesdames
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mes chers collègues à l'heure où tous
les regards du monde se portent encore
une fois sur la poudrière du Proche
Orient dans l'attente anxieuse de sa
probable explosion permettez-moi d'avoir
une pensée émue pour toutes les victimes
de ce conflit et en particulier pour nos
30 compatriotes assassinés par les
terroristes du Hamas et les neuf
Français encore portés disparus que nous
espérons toujours vivant car oui le
Hamas est bien une organisation
terroriste parmi les plus horribles et
si certains avaient encore un doute les
cabre découverte de leurs svic et de
leurs crimes les plus abjects depuis le
7 octobre n'en laisse plus aucun aux
hommes et aux femmes de bonne volonté
seul d'indiges calcul électoraux et
d'infames idéologies pourrai inciter des
politiques irresponsables à qualifier
les actes du Hamas ou cette organisation
de résistance souillant ainsi ce beau
mot pour lequel tant de français sont
morts face à cette barbarie Israël seule
vraie démocratie du Proche Orient a le
droit et même le devoir de défendre sa
population dans le respect bien sûr du
droit international
dans ce contexte extrêmement tendu et
animé de mauvaise passion l'on aurait pu
espérer une voix française forte
au-dessus de la mêlé hélas trois fois
hélas cette voix française est portée
depuis plus de 6 ans par un homme qui
avait déclaré avant d'accéder au plus
hautes fonction qu' n'y avait pas de
culture française comment finalement lui
reprocher de ne pas comprendre ce qui
fait sa singularité ce qui fait que
cette voix française était autrefois
attendu écouté et respecté parmi dans le
monde entier notamment au Proche Orient
où l'histoire nous avait donné une place
particulière loin de saisir l'enjeu
crucial du moment le président de la
République a préféré le lendemain des
carnages du 7 octobre se rendre en
Allemagne pour un séminaire
intergouvernemental puis en Albanie dont
il veut apparemment faire un nouveau
membre de l'UE contre toute logique et
contre toutes les opinions publiques il
aura fallu attendre 17 jours pour qu'il
atterrisse en fin en Israël bien après
tous les autres dirigeants européens
mais pour y dire quoi puisque notre
singularité n'est plus que dira le
président de la République que Nura dit
un Olaf Scholz ou même unea van derleyen
qui se prend apparemment pour une chef
d'État pour que la France porte que sa
voix porte à nouveau il faut retrouver
notre tradition diplomatique alliée mais
non alignée forte car libre et constante
dans le temps c'est tout l'objectif de
la Déclaration des droits des peuples et
des nations que Marine Le Pen a présenté
il y a quelques semaines les grands
principes énoncés dans cette charte a
commencé par l'égalité en dignité et en
droit de tous les peuples et les nations
pourrait servir de guide pour trouver
demain un règlement au conflit
israë-palestinien prémiss à la
normalisation des relations
interétatiques au Proche Orient cette
proposition pourra devenir un outil que
la France de tout temp créatrice de
droit nouveaux pourra porter dans le
monde notre pays retrouvera ainsi cette
place si particulière dans le concert
des nations que beaucoup de pays du
Proche Orient attendent à nouveau cette
place qui lui parla qui lui permet en
même temps d'assurer la sécurité des
Français de promouvoir nos intérêts
nationaux et de rester fidèle à notre
histoire tel que clémenau le disait ici
même à cette tribune le 11 deembre 118
la France sera toujours le soldat de
l'idéal je vous
remercie merci chers collègues pour
répondre aux orateurs la parole est
désormais à Monsieur Olivier betch
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité et des
Français de l'étranger monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
souhaiterais pouvoir
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions qui ont été posé lors des
interventions des différents orateurs en
commençant peut-être par la question
relative à
l'extension au Hamas à la lutte contre
le Hamas de la coalition internationale
contre le
terrorisme vous nous interrogez pour
savoir quelles sont les formes que
pourrait prendre cette extension je
rappelle simplement que la coalition qui
a été mise en place contre
daesh n'implique pas excl exclusivement
des actions militaires sur le terrain
mais également un certain nombre
d'actions à la fois en matière de
renseignement en matière de lutte contre
le financement du terrorisme ou encore
en matière de lutte contre le djihadisme
en ligne et sur les réseaux sociaux le
président de la République vient
d'ailleurs de déclarer que cette lutte
contre le terrorisme nécessite la
coopération de tous et que c'est le prix
nécessaire pour assurer la sécurité et
la paix dans la région je souhaitais
également euh rassurer euh le président
rotillo qui nous demande une tolérance
zéro contre l'antisémitisme c'est bien
euh la politique du gouvernement euh la
question sur l'aide humanitaire pour
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas un €o
qui euh aille au Hamas euh notre aide
humanitaire passe évidemment par les
agences euh de l'organisation des
nations- Unies notamment NRA et le PAM
ainsi que par le CICR et différentses
ONG et nous veillons tout
particulièrement évidemment à ce que pas
1 € ne termine à destination du Hamas je
remercie le sénateur Kadic d'avoir
mentionn les 30 français qui ont été
assassinés par le Hamas ainsi que les
neuf toujours disparus et vous assure
que nous déployons tous les efforts pour
qu'il soit ramené en ce qui concerne les
otages à l'affection de leur famille je
voulais également rassurer euh sur la
pleine implication de notre diplomatie
pour le président Claude maluré et la
présidente Marise carer euh
sur la question de l'escalade nous
sommes évidemment pleinement molisés
pour éviter tout escalade dans la région
et particulièrement également euh pour
la préservation des accords d'Abraham
qui est une priorité également de notre
diplomatie enfin si la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
n'est pas ici au banc ce soir c'est
parce qu'elle est elle-même au Conseil
de sécurité des Nations unies pleinement
impliqué où nous demandons maintenant
depuis plus d'une semaine une trêve
humanitaire avec à terme un cesser le
feu qui est une condition évidemment à
ce qu'on puisse reprendre les
négociations politique pour assurer
cette solution à deux états mesames et
messieurs les sénateurs je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le ministre pour conclure
ce débat je vais donner la parole à
madame la Première ministre Madame
Élisabeth
borne merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs alors que ce débat touche à sa
fin je souhaite remercier les oratrices
et orateurs de tous les groupes
politiques vous l'avez tous dit la
situation est grave elle exigeait un
débat respectueux un débat à la hauteur
des
circonstances cela a été le cas et je
tiens à le
saluer nos parcours nos idées donc nos
visions ne sont pas les mêmes nos
sensibilités peuvent parfois différer
c'est la démocratie mais au-delà de ces
divergces nos points de vuees se
rejoignent sur plusieurs points
essentiels c'est important
particulièrement dans de telles
circonstances premièrement je constate
un large consensus pour condamner sans
ambigué l'attaque terroriste du Hamas
sur
Israël un consensus pour nommer
l'agression barbare dont a été victime
ce pays pour dénoncer l'horreur et la
tragédie que constituent ces
attentats les mots ont un sens refuser
d'en prononcer certains en a également
un ici au Sénat personne n'a d'état
d'âme pour qualifier le Hamas de groupe
terroriste et je veux le saluer et
collectivement nous reconnaissons à
Israël le droit d'assurer sa défense
dans le respect du droit
international le deuxième point qui nous
rassemble largement c'est la volonté de
protéger les civil et l'attention pour
les populations de
Gaza nous nous accordons pour affirmer
que les populations palestiniennes sont
également les victimes du Hamas nous
nous accordons pour dénoncer la
catastrophe humanitaire en cours à Gaza
et la mort de milliers de civils
palestiniens il n'y a pas de double de
double standard face aux victimes nous
les pleurons toutes pas de double
standard face aux civils tous doivent
être protégés la position de la France
est claire et je l'ai réaffirmé devant
vous nous appelons à des trêves
humanitaires qui pourront mener à un
cesser le feu et à l'accès immédiat et
sécurisé de l'aide vers
Gaza enfin je note un troisième point
d'accord c'est notre recherche de la
paix
durable comme vous je crois que nous
devons tout faire pour éviter un
embrasement régional et comme je l'ai
dit en
introduction je suis convaincu que par
notre histoire notre voix indépendante
la France a un rôle à jouer à court
terme comme de manière plus durable pour
bâtir la paix et une solution politique
à ce conflit c'est précisément dans
cette optique que le Président de la
République est dans la région
aujourd'hui tout faire pour éviter
l'escalade et créer les conditions d'une
reprise du processus politique pour une
solution à deux états et comme le
président de la République vient de le
déclarer après son entretien avec le
président Mahmoud Abbas nous sommes
convaincus qu'une initiative forte pour
la paix et la sécurité doit être
conduite la quête légitime de sécurité
est une illusion tant qu'une paix juste
n'est pas établie mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs si notre débat portait sur
la situation au Proche Orient vous avez
exprimé au cours de vos interv tion des
inquiétudes sur l'impact de ce conflit
dans notre pays ces inquiétudes nous les
entendons nous y répondons avec le
président de la République et tout le
gouvernement nous continuons à combattre
inlassablement l'antisémitisme sous
toutes ses
formes l'antisémitisme est un poison et
comme toutes les haines il n'a pas sa
place dans notre République dans ce
combat notre détermination est totale
dès l'attaque cont cont Israël avec le
président de la République nous avons
demandé au ministre de l'Intérieur
d'adresser un message de vigilance au
préfet et aux forces de l'ordre nous
avons aussi réhaussé la protection des
lieux sensibles en particulier les
écoles et les lieux de culte grâce
notamment à l'opération
sentinelle comme je l'ai indiqué hier
depuis le 7 octobre plus de 300
personnes ont été arrêtées pour des
actes ou des menaces antisémites nous
avons aussi reçu plus de 4000 alertes
via la plateforme Faros pour des
contenus eux en ligne plus de 300
d'entre elles sont désormais entre les
mains de la justice dans l'objectif
d'identifier et de punir leurs auteurs
nous ne faiblirons pas face au fléau de
l'antisémitisme en ligne comme dans la
rue nous ne laisserons rien
passer enfin je veux condamner à nouveau
l'attitude de ceux qui voudraient
utiliser ce conflit comme prétexte à
toutes les outrances toutes les dérives
notamment à des fins électoralistes
c'est irresponsable c'est dangereux pour
notre pacte
républicain je me réjouis que cette
position soit largement partagée dans
les travers du Sénat mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les
circonstances sont graves et dans ces
moments nous avons un devoir de cohésion
nationale un devoir de
responsabilité un devoir de dire les
choses et de ne pas attiser les tension
de notre société je sais pouvoir compter
sur le Sénat dans cet
objectif avec le gouvernement c'est
toujours la voie que nous choisirons et
avec le président de la République nous
défendrons toujours le chemin de la
justice et de la paix c'est l'honneur et
la singularité de la France de rester
une nation indépendante capable de se
tenir au côté du peuple israélien comme
du peuple palestinien je vous remercie
merci madame la Première ministre mes
chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 21h pour la
suite de l'examen de la proposition de
loi visant à améliorer l'accès aux soins
par l'engagement territorial des
professionnels la séance est
[Musique]
levée